Bayne: One thing
you need to think about
is if you want
your web application
to behave
like a normal website,
then you need to worry
about what the back button does.
And GWT provides
a history class
that allows you
to integrate with the back--
with the sort of
browser history.
But you need to think
about how that influences
the structure
of your application.
Because it's easy
to write something
that works
like a desktop application,
but then the back button
doesn't actually do
what you would expect.
And so if you want things
to sort of meet
a user's expectations
in that regard,
you need to kind of
structure your applications
so that it has
a sort of history itself.